up here you're a sparkline so we're
trying to get more dynamic shots dogs
and sledding the goal is to do a
slow-motion shot of Andy leaving with
the dogs because they're all excited and
we want to be just right over the top of
the sled as they go underneath us so
right now we've cobbled together a
ladder on the trees it's slightly
dangerous
that's an awesome shot we're gonna do
one more dynamic shop building a tiny
little shelter for the camera
underground when the cameras sitting
down here looking out get the dog
sleeping slow motion through our frame
that's the hope the trick is to bury it
and support it enough that it can take
the weight and not ruin our camera so
here we go I'm happy with a shot it
looks like I missed my level of teeny
bit but since we like weird angles on
the show it'll work
this is the dangerous one because as the
dogs come towards us they don't like
seeing this see what happened
push the border hope I didn't ruin it
that's the button throats trials and
tribulations yeah we got the shot
when we're out filming you got a dress
warm you don't want any air getting in
because if it can layer up like a lot
these boots here these are there in - I
think 148 below zero that is been crap
then next up here's a neck gaiter I put
this on over my face and neck zip that
up over and a waffle here for extremely
cold days is a really warm really sick
down jacket heading out to a film scene
work oh I want to get this shot just
moving around to try to get a shot you
got all these different layers of
clothing on it's an ongoing chore and
try to get your shot and you have no
dexterity when you're filming trying to
find focus with love's on it's the
challenge showing up only been out here
maybe 20 minutes or so yeah they hate
the length of the Arctic like Falaise
Europe